quả lý đe điều và phòng trong thín tay bộ nông nghiệp và mối chương vừa đưa ra
mùi mùi mùi khuyên cáo nhằm tăng cửa kiến năng ưu phó với báo xù ba và mũ lũ sâu báo,
bởi đảm ăn tòn tiếng mạng và tại sản trong người dân.
Mùi theo dõi chật chế thung tín dự báo, cạnh báo thín tay từ các cơ quan chức nằm.
2. Bởi đảm ăn tòn tầu thuyền nơi nhau đậu, đứa đối không ở lại trên tầu, choi thanh,
lòng bệ khí báo đủ bộ.
3. Hạ chế dù lịch trong bộ mưa báo không dí trình đến vụ vihi em không dáng ngoài khí báo đủ bộ nếu không cần thiết.
Bốn, xó định và chuẩn bị nơi trù ở nạn toàn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn tán khí cỏi yêu cầu.
5. Dự chữ nhùi vầm thuốc man nước uống đầy đủ.
6. Dạ cố nhạc gửi chặt tiền kê sanh thảo dưới các vật dễ bị giò của nc.
7. Tram lo Chanel straps nói sót n cavalry vاط ...
8. Truy động phòng lửa luộng quept s Drum lửa ở đây, nhất lạ tại khu vụ mir Luis
Xuếng, kê cào tại tài sàn d ei trên Feng Tagers các giửa dày tửa quan trọng.
7. Cuớ thông con bản, và nước không đâu hươngeuner sẽ tại Đối Rệ Ngọt明
15. L used tác xuль thỏa phần cấp để lứa hề khi cảnh thiết.
Theo thống K, thinh Thai trong sảo tháng đầu năm nay đặc hiện bởi mỹ tư với chết và mất tích, hơn năm 1960
thích thải tại sản hơn 20 bi động, tăng gần 1 phẩy hai lần so với cuộc kì năm 2020.